هاي هاي
في حد هنا يعرف هاري بوتر او اتليست معه
اي سي ناس كتير في القاضي
بحسه انهاري بوتر مرتبط بطفلات معظمنا لان
تقريبا ده الوقت اللي اتفرجنا على هاري
بوتر فيه
وعايزين نروح بقى نتعلم
نعرف احنا هاوس ايه انا
من فتره للتانيه بحب ان انا اتفرج عليها
هاري بوتر لانه بحس ان هو ماي كونفرتون
فبحب ان انا ارجع اكون في الزوم بتاعتي من
قريب كنت بتفرج على اخدت بالي من حاجه في
الصين بتاع هاري لما كانوا في الليك
والدمام ترسله عليهم وابتدوا ان هم يساقط
سولدم
عرفنا ان هاري هيك
وانقذهم من الباترون
هي كائنات الشريره الوحشه اللي بتسحب اعطف
بايبل وبتتغذى على كل النجاتيف
واي حاجه انت متخيله انها وحشه في حياتك
كان اسهل ان الدماسر دول يموتوك عندي
قدرهاند الباترون هي الحاجه الوحيده اللي
هتقدر تنقذك من الضمان ودي سبال هم
بيتعلموها بانهم يستجمعوا كل الممرز
السعيده في حياتهم وتبقى هي دي بتاعهم
لو قلت لك ان ده بيحصل في حياتنا الطبيعيه
بتاعه كل يوم بس طبعا بشكل مختلف يعني
الديوز هي كل نجتيف تقعد كل احساس بالضعف
عدم الايمان كل لحظه فشل لحظه وحده اي
احساس نجتيف او اي كلمه نجتيف قالت لك هي
دي الدمانت اللي في حياتك
والباترون بتاعتك هيثم
يعني ايه انكر اصلا
الانكر دي هي الماساه اللي بتثبت سفينه
كامله في مكانها تخيلوا سفينه كامله
مثبتها قطعه حديد مجرد حديد بتثبت السفينه
وقت العاصفه لما يكون في عاصفه شديده جدا
لو السفينه دي اتحركت هتغرق
بتثبت السفينه مكانها لما تبقى عايزه
تتصين تاخد راحه وبعد كده تكمل طريقها
عادي بتثبت السفينه مكانها لما تروح بره
الامان وتبقى مطمنه ان ما فيش رحلات تاني
خلاص احنا وصلنا
طب انا بقول كل ده ليه هل انا دلوقتي هاري
بوتر ولا انا سفينه ولا انا مش فاهم اي
حاجه هفهمك
بتستخدم للناس اللي عندها علشان تخف من
حده الانزايتي تاكس بتاعتهم شويه بس اللي
احنا ما نعرفوش انكر ما فيش مره عديته على
شارع او سمعت اغنيه وافتكرته حد موجود في
حياتكم دلوقتي او مش موجود ما فيش في مره
شميته ريحه عيش نفس العيش اللي كنتوا معاك
وانتو رايحين المدرسه الساعه 7:00 الصبح
ما فيش في مره اكلته اكله فافتكرته جدتكم
وهي بتعمل الاكل ده يوم الجمعه بعد الصلاه
هي دي نفس فكره بالضبط انت بتربط احساس
انت حسيته في موقف معين من كثر ما الموقف
ده كان مؤثر في حياتك اتكرر ممكن من كتر
ما هو كان موقف بجد تريلين في حياتك وانت
حسيت احساس فيه بقى كل ما الموقف ده يحصل
ويتكرر تاني بتحس نفس الاحساس بالظبط سواء
حلو او وحش
احكي لكم قصه ثانويه عامه انا كنت قلقانه
جدا جدا من الكميه هي كانت كلها اكويلاز
وانا بحب الملف انا مليش في الكيمياء خالص
فكانت بالنسبه لي صعب قوي وطريقه مذاكرتها
كانت غريبه علي وكنت طول السنه بجيب فيها
درجات وحشه جدا جدا وكل اللي انا بفكر فيه
انا هعمل ايه في الفاينال بتاعتي ما فيهاش
ان انا اخد ما فيش ان انا بسبب ماده
اخر كم شهر حاولت ان انا الم الدنيا
وحاولت ان انا اغير طريقه مذاكرتي حاولت
طبعا انتم عارفين قبل النتيجه بتاعه
ثانويه عامه بيبقى فيها كهرباء غير مبرره
والنتيجه خرجت من الكنترول لا لسه ما
خرجتش طب ابعتي لي رقم جلوسك فبقى اي
تليفون بيحصل في البيت النتيجه طلعت كهربا
غير طبيعيه وتوتر وقلق وشديت اعصاب يوم
النتيجه بتاعتي كان في رمضان وللاسف كان
بعد الفطار الناس كلها بتصلي وبتصوم
وبتفطر وبتدعي وانا قاعده حاطه وشي في
اللابتوب انا عايزه اخلص عايزه النتيجه
بتاعتي تطلع اول ما النتيجه طلعت اول حاجه
بصيت عليها كانت درجه مش التوتال
مش هقدر اوصف لكم قد ايه انا حسيت بالرليف
وقد ايه حسيت
بالانبساط وقد ايه انا ارتحت ان اخيرا يا
رب اخيرا
انا كنت شايله همها وكنت متخيله ان انا
هاخد بسببها وماده كانت عامله لي
انا قفلتها
ماده انا كنت متخيله ان انا هغير بتاعتي
كلها بسببها انا ما جيتش فيها درجه حلوه
جيت فيها درجه عاليه انا قفلتها
افتكر ان انا يومها ماما كانت عامله حته
صينيه بشاميل بحلف بيها لحد النهارده ومن
ساعتها والبشاميل بقت مرتبطه معي باينت
انا بعمله اتخرجت خليت ماما تعمل لي
بشاميل لقيت شغل خليت ماما تعملي بشاميل
حتى لو الناس كلموني هنا خليت ماما تعمل
لي بشاميل
في الاول قلنا انس مرتبطه
طب ازاي انت دلوقتي داخل على حاجه بالنسبه
لك دخل على حاجه جديده انت ما تعرفهاش دخل
على حاجه انت مش عارف اولها من اخرها مش
عارفه تبداها ازاي ولا امتى ومش عارف لو
بداتها هتخلصها ولا لا مش عارف لو خلصتها
هتعمل ايه ولو ما خلصتهاش هتعمل ايه مش
عارف نتيجه تعبك ومجهودك ووئتك اللي انت
هتحطه ده هترجعلك ثاني ولا مش هترجع خلاص
كده كل ده ممكن يسبب انزايتي ممكن يسبب
توتر لاي حد طبيعي ممكن مايكونش عنده
انزايتي اصلا وبرضو يتوتر
ده بيجيب فكره في دماغك ان مجرد فكره هي
اللي ممكن تثبتك في مكانك هي تقول لك
استنى اثبت لما هتعمل واحد اتنين تلاته
هتلاقي قدامها واحد اتنين تلاته لما هتمشي
في الطريق ده هتلاقي كده ولما تمشي في
الطريق ده هتلاقي كده ولما تقع انا اللي
هقومك ما تقلقش
نفس الفكره دي برضو هي اللي ممكن تسهرك
تلات ايام في حاجه حصلت وانت في ابتدائي
واحده شدت شعرك وانت صغيره كله ضحك عليك
نفس الفكره هي اللي ممكن تشجعك وتخليك
تكملي وتفلفلي
كل اللي انا بحكي فيه ده اتخلقت في دماغنا
اوتوماتيك من حده الموقف ومن شدته خلقت
لنا قالت طب ليه ما نجربش اننا نعمل سوا
تعالوا نفكر فيها
ايه اكتر موقف لما بتفتكروه بتبتسموا
تلقائيا ايه اكتر موقف لما بتحبوا ان
انتوا تبقوا مبسوطين او ترتاحوا بتفتكروا
الموقف ده اكثر لحظه حسيته ان ربنا كرمكم
بجد النتيجه بتاعتكم اهي قدامكم اكتر موقف
بتحسه بالانجاز
بالاتشيفنت اللي انتم عملتوه في حياتكم
الموقف ده هو ده الكود بتاعتك وهي دي اللي
هتشجعك بعد كده
وعلى فكره مش شرط ان تبقى مجرد نمري هي
ممكن تكون حاجه انت بتسعى لها حاجه انت
عايز توصل لها وبتشتغل عليها دلوقتي ونفسك
انها تحصل والاحساس اللي هتحس لما توصل
للحاجه دي هو ده الموت بتاعك وهو ده اللي
هيشجعك
عرفنا ايه هي الانكصات وعرفنا بنعملها
ازاي وعرفنا بتتخلق في دماغنا ازاي
هنستخدمها امتى
اي لحظه انت عايز الانكصات بتاعتك فيها
هستخدمها على طول متوتر قلقان خايف عندك
امتحان شغل برزنتيشن اي لحظه انت حاسس
فيها انك محتاج بتاعتك هتستخدمها على طول
بس خلي بالك ان كل تريجر من دول هيبقى
محتاج انكر مختلف عن الثاني يعني طبعا مش
تبقى داخل الامتحان وبتفكر في صينيه
البشاميل هتبقى داخل الامتحان وانت بتفكر
ان الله لا يضيع اجر من احسن عملا هتبقى
داخل الامتحان وانت بتفكر ان نتيجه تعبك
ومجهودك وسهرك ورايح من الدرس جاي من
الدرس ومذاكره اللي انت عمال بتذاكرها دي
خلاص كلها ثلاث اربع ساعات وترتاح من كل
ده ونتيجه تعبك هتشوفه اضعاف اضعاف ما انت
متخيل عشان انت واثق في ربنا وعارف ان
ربنا ما بيعملش حاجه وحشه
عرفتوا ايه هي الانقساط بتاعتكم
عرفتوا ايه هي الباترون اللي تحميكم من
الدمانترز اللي في حياتكم
[تصفيق]